the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our main aim today is to successfully
conclude block three and to set the
stage for introducing block 4 now by way
of brief review we may have become so
involved with our discussion of the last
few lessons where we've done the chain
rule that we may have forgotten that the
basic ingredient that we had arrived
that that set up our proof of the chain
rule and then after that we got involved
in the computation of how to use the
chain rule but the basic ingredient was
the idea that we had obtained a linear
approximation a Delta W tan idea and
this concept leads to the idea of a
differential which is an extension of
the idea of differentials as we knew
them in part 1 of our course and what I
would like to do is to talk somewhat
briefly about this topic to show how it
introduces what will be the main body of
material in block 4 and an important
application that we can handle now that
will show why it's worth understanding
certain things about differentials even
on a very elementary level any rate the
topical have chosen for today is called
exact differentials and the idea again
is completely analogous to what we did
in calculus of a single variable we
start with W equals f of X Y and we
showed that if W was a continuously
differentiable function of X and y it
made sense to emphasize the expression
called Delta W tan
which was the partial of effort respect
to X evaluated the given point times
Delta X plus the partial of F with
respect to Y at that same point times
Delta Y and what we do is the same thing
that we did as I say in calculus of a
single variable we introduce a new
language we write Delta W 10 now as DW
we write Delta X as DX Delta Y as dy and
what we say is that DW is the total
differential of W to see how this is
analogous to what happened in calculus
of a single variable notice for the sake
of argument that if F happens to be a
function of X alone so
there is no second variable in other
words if f is independent of Y notice
that the partial with effort respect to
Y will be zero and we will then have
that W is a function of X alone DW then
will be what well in that case the
partial of F with respect to X is the
ordinary derivative of effort respect to
x times DX and we're back to our old
recipe that DW is DW DX times DX that
this is a natural extension of what
happened in calculus of a single
variable alright now what leads into the
next block and what will and why we're
going to drop this for the time being
but to go up to a different aspect of
this is notice that if we can assume
that DW can replace Delta W if we can
assume as we as we talked about in the
case of continuously differentiable
functions that the difference between
Delta W and Delta W 10 is negligible
for sufficiently small Delta X and Delta
Y notice that the equation D W equals F
sub X DX plus F sub y dy since F sub X
and F sub y are computed a given point
these become what linear combinations of
DX and dy a constant times DX plus a
constant times dy and we're into the
subject of linear equations which we
will talk about next time for the time
being all I want to point out is that
the W is called the total differential
of W and that conversely starting with
any expression of the form some function
M of X + y times DX plus some function n
of x + y times dy in other words M of X
Y DX + n of X Y dy no matter what
functions of x + y m and n are any
expression of this form is called a
differential by the way you may recall
that you were used to calling DX a
differential back in calculus of a
single variable
notice that in particular one choice of
capital n is to have n of X Y be
identically 0 we could have M of XY be
identically 1 in which case MDX plus NDY
would simply be 1 DX plus 0 dy or DX in
other words notice that this extended
definition of a differential for two or
more variables includes the definition
for a single variable
at any rate any expression of this type
is called a differential and again a
very natural question that comes up is
who wants differentials why do we need
them and perhaps the best application
comes from the clue that a certain
subject is called differential equations
rather than derivative equations let me
illustrate this in terms of a blessing
there's a rather nice example in the
sense that it will be hard to guess the
answer but rather easy to visualize what
the problem says at least let's imagine
I have a certain curve s in the XY plane
I don't tell you anything else about
that curve except that it's slope at any
point X comma Y is given by the very
interesting relationship that it's the
quotient of the square of its distance
from the origin over twice the product
of its coordinates in other words to
find the slope of the curve S at the
point X comma Y I square the distance of
the point from the origin take the
negative of that divided by twice the
product of the coordinates and that's
going to be the slope now certainly that
makes sense geometrically but what type
of a curve would have that property and
even assuming that we knew such a curve
how in the world can you express it in a
convenient manner well here's the idea
again back to the same technique that we
use in calculus of a single variable
algebraically this is our equation if we
cross multiply and collect all our terms
onto one side of the equation we obtain
what we call the differential equation
see it's an equation involving a
differential in fact in this case using
our general notation M of X Y is x
squared plus y squared and n of X Y is
2xy we have a differential equal to zero
now without going into this right now
suppose I just happen to have a very
quick eye when fact before I even say
that let me point this out we've had
problems like this in part one of our
course the main difference was is that
we could separate out the variables we
could get the X's and the Y separated
remember now Y is implicitly a function
of X here in this expression because of
the equation C X and y are no longer
independent when we equate this to 0
the question is though we cannot solve
or separate the XS and the Y's here but
if we were lucky that's where luck comes
in we would recognize that treating Y as
a function of X the differential on the
left hand side is precisely the
differential of 1/3 X cubed plus x
squared Y in other words the partial of
this with respect to X is simply x
squared oh do I have this I think I may
have this thing in Reverse let me make
sure if I take the partial of this with
respect to X I have 1/3 X cubed plus 2xy
right and if I take the partial with
respect to Y I simply have x squared any
rate what I'm saying is if we knew a
function whose saheb this in Reverse
that's what's bothering me here I think
the square should go this way that's
time to put all I'm saying is if I've
done this thing correctly if you take
the partial of this with respect to Y
with respect to X you should get this if
we take the partial of this with respect
to Y you should get this and that comes
out correctly now in other words the
partial of this with respect to X is x
squared plus y squared the partial of
this with respect to Y this term drops
out and is just 2xy I'm sorry for that
little mistake but I won't really
apologize for it in the sense that once
we've found it or even if we didn't find
that the key theory is the same the
point is that if we knew a function
whose differential was this then the
fact that this differential is zero
means the expression itself must be a
constant
in other words one third x cubed plus X
Y squared must be a constant and
therefore what we're saying is if we now
solve the equation am I really am sorry
to have watched this for you but again
as I say the idea basically comes
through unimpeded I now solve for y in
terms of X and I get what that Y is
equal to transposing here plus or minus
the square root of C minus 1/3 x cubed
all over X in other words the family of
curves that satisfies this differential
equation
is precisely this family here whatever
that may look like in other words this
is the family of curves that has the
interesting slope property that we just
discussed now you see again the reason I
say that I wasn't too concerned about
what this function actually was is
notice that I was just pulling it out of
a hat for you here anyway I said suppose
we could find a function W such that DW
was this the major question that comes
up and how one uses differentials and
the like is as follows suppose all I
told you was that we had the
differential x squared plus y squared DX
plus 2x y dy and I said to you find a
function W such that DW will be x
squared plus y squared DX plus 2x y dy
the key computational aid in doing this
involves the fact that if u and V are
independent variables and it's crucial
that they be independent that if a u
plus B V equals C u plus DV it must be
that a equals C and B equals D in other
words the only way that two linear
combinations of independent variables
can be equal as if they're equal
coefficient by coefficient you see the
proof is very simple namely after all if
u and V are independent variables why
can't I pick V to be 0 let u be any
nonzero number then if V is 0 when I
equate these two it says au week we'll
see you since u is not 0 I can cancel
and obtain data equals C and in a
similar way letting u equals 0 I have B
V equals DV I can cancel the V's and get
that B equals D but it's crucial that
you and V be independent because if u
and V are not independent how do I know
that I can have u equal to 0 when V is
not 0 for example let's suppose that V
and u were dependent suppose for example
that V equals twice you observe in this
case that 9 u plus 4 V since V is 2 u
turns out to be 17 you on the other hand
7 u plus 5 V is 7 u plus 10 u which is
also 17 you notice that 9 u plus 4 V
equals 7 u
5-v even though the coefficients don't
line up as far as being equally
concerned you see in other words notice
that being able to equate things
coefficient by coefficient hinges on the
fact that the variables that we're
dealing with our independent and the key
thing going back to this problem is what
were DX and dy they were Delta X and
Delta Y and as long as x and y are
independent variables certainly the
change in X is independent can be done
independently of the change in Y in
other words DX and dy are independent
variables so if we now say let's find
that function W such that DW is x
squared plus y squared DX is X y plus y
squared DX plus 2xy dy the one thing we
know about the W if it exists by our
basic definition of this section of this
lecture is that DW is the partial of F
with respect to x times DX plus the
partial of F with respect to Y times dy
since DX and dy are independent
variables the only way these two
expressions can be identical is
coefficient by coefficient that means in
particular therefore that the partial of
F with respect to X which is the
coefficient of DX here must be x squared
plus y squared which is the coefficient
of DX here and similarly the partial of
f with respect to y must equal to XY now
armed with this information I can
actually go out and construct F and the
way I do this is remember as soon as I
see the partial of F with respect to X
it means I'm treating Y as a constant
if I'm treating Y as a constant I just
integrate this thing as if X were the
only variable treating X as a variable
and Y is a constant the integral of x
squared is 1/3 X cubed the integral of Y
squared is simply Y squared X because Y
is being treated as a constant and
finally there must be a constant of
integration but my constant now is any
function of Y in other words if if I
have any function of Y its partial with
respect to X by definition of x and y
being independent the partial of any
function of Y with respect to X is 0
therefore my constant of integration in
this case is a function of Y alone again
look at this in a different perspective
what I'm saying is the most general
function of two variables in the whole
world whose derivative with respect to X
is X square plus y squared is 1/3 X
cubed plus y squared X plus a function
of Y alone now all I don't know so far
is what specific function of Y is G in
other words I've determined F now up to
this particular arbitrary constant of
integration how do I get ahold of this
thing notice still as yet I have not
used the piece of information that tells
me the partial of F with respect to Y is
2xy and to utilize that piece of
information what I do is I come to this
equation and I say look at let me from
here just differentiate this with
respect to Y treating X as a constant if
I do that this term drops out this term
becomes 2xy and this being a function of
Y alone it's derivative respect to Y is
just G prime of Y so whatever F is F the
derivative F with respect to Y is 2xy
plus G prime of Y on the other hand we
also know that the partial of F with
respect to Y is 2xy consequently since
these are two different expressions for
the same quantity they must be equal
equating these two the 2x wise cancel we
obtained that G prime of Y is 0 which
means in this case that G of Y was a
bonafide
constant that not only is G independent
of X it's also independent of Y and we
see it the most general function f which
has the desired property is what all we
have to do is now go back to this
expression here which gave us the answer
up to G of Y put this value of G of Y in
and we see it the most general function
whose total differential is x squared
plus y squared DX plus 2x y dy is 1/3 x
cubed plus y squared X plus C and I
guess there's a moral to this story
after all you know when I do it the
quick way I made a kill us
computational mistake earlier in the
lecture that sort of threw me off a bit
and perplexed me and it seems it was
point of justice because you know when I
took this method
we pretended we didn't know the answer
in advance and just worked the thing out
systematically we came up with the right
term in other words it should be Y
squared X not Y x squared and that was
what we saw should be the correct answer
so maybe there's something to be said
about doing things systematically after
all you see if I can't win them all at
least I have the gift of rationalizing
to think that I win them all
time after time I snatch defeat from the
jaws of victory No all right you know
what I mean look at anyway the question
that was now solved is what we have
worked out this routine notice that what
we are really doing is the counterpart
of calculus of a single variable that
knowing what a partial is we can
integrate with respect to that variable
treating all the other variables as a
constant and this is the general
technique now let's summarize this more
generally the general definition is this
and by the way for the sake of
conserving space
I will now abbreviate M of X Y and n of
X Y just by M and n but whenever I write
m and n here it's assumed that m and n
are functions of x and y support what we
say is this MDX plus NDY
which by the way by a previous
definition is always a differential but
this differential is called an exact
differential if and only if there exists
a function W f of X Y such that DW is
MDX plus NDY or in terms of our previous
discussion what this means is what DW is
also equal to F sub X DX plus F sub y dy
since x and y are independent variables
DX and dy are independent variables so
an alternative definition is what that
MDX plus NDY is an exact differential if
there exists a function f such that the
partial of F with respect to X is M and
the partial of effort respect to Y is n
now by the way let's just pause here for
a moment you might suspect that with all
the functions to choose from that no
matter how m and n were given we're
bound to find at least one function
which satisfies I should put this in
because you want both
these conditions fulfill at the same
time the amazing thing is that it is not
always possible to find a function which
has a given differential as its total
differential in fact let me show you why
if we can just do something a little bit
tricky here let's suppose that the
function f exists such that it's partial
with respect to X is M and it's partial
with respect to Y is n suppose that both
of these happen to be differentiable
take the partial of F sub X with respect
to Y that tells me that F sub XY is the
partial of M with respect to Y let's
take the partial of F sub y with respect
to X that tells me that the partial of F
sub y at respect to axes and sub X in
other words F sub y x equals n sub X now
if F is continuing
see if if we have the right amount of
continuity and differentiability that
we've talked about in previous lectures
notice that for most well-defined
functions in particular if these two
partials we don't know where they're
fizz we're trying to find F and we're
assuming it exists the thing that's
given in our definition I M and n so the
word this more succinctly if it turns
out that the partial of M with respect
to Y and the partial of n with respect
to X happen to be continuous functions
notice that these two things are equal
and in particular that means that the
partial of M with respect to Y has to
equal the partial of n with respect to X
coming back to the original definition
here this is a rather amazing thing it
says that if this differential is exact
if you take the coefficient of DX you
think of M as being the coefficient of
DX and n as being the coefficient of dy
if you take the coefficient of DX and
differentiate that with respect to Y you
must get the same answer as if you took
the coefficient of dy and differentiated
that with respect to X that's an amazing
coincidence if that happens given two
arbitrary functions this indeed won't
happen now before I show you that let's
summarize this in words written down so
that I make sure that you understand
what I'm saying what I'm saying is if
the partial of M with respect to Y and
the partial of n with respect to X are
continuous
if M DX plus n dy is exact the
implication is that the partial of M
with respect to Y must equal the partial
of n with respect to X and to invert the
emphasis here another way of saying this
is that if the partial of M with respect
to Y is not equal to the partial of n
with respect to X then MDX plus NDY is
not exact and let me show you that by
means of an example let's look at the
differential a very simple looking one
in fact it looks far less complicated
than the expression that we work with
previously
let's look simply at Y DX minus X dy in
this problem the coefficient of DX is y
that plays the role of M the coefficient
of dy is minus X that's what we're
calling n you see and the partial of M
with respect to Y is just the partial of
Y with respect to Y which is 1 the
partial of n with respect to X is the
partial of minus X with respect to X
which is minus 1 since 1 is not equal to
minus 1 this is not exact because if it
were exact these two partials will have
to be equal what does it mean to say
that this is not exact what it means is
that there is not a single function in
the whole world that has the property
that it's partial with respect to X is y
and it's partial with respect to Y is
minus X you can look forever and not
only won't you find one there isn't one
and by the way let me make one very
quick aside here notice the difference
between saying you can't find one and
there isn't one there may be one and
you're just not lucky enough to find it
I'm saying that the reason you don't
find an answer here unless you make a
mistake and think you've found an answer
the reason you don't find an answer is
there is none and how can I show you
that there is none well the best way is
to do the same thing that we did in the
previous example and see something go
wrong let's suppose that we're an answer
to this well if the partial of f with
respect to x equals y let me integrate
this with respect to X treating Y as a
constant it means that the function that
I'm looking for
must have what form it's x times y plus
some function of Y alone and now we say
see we're in pretty good shape all we've
got to do is find what G of Y is and
we're home
three let's continue to mimic what we
did before knowing this I can take the
partial of this with respect to Y okay
which is what if I take the partial of
this with respect to Y this is F sub y
is X plus G prime of Y all right now
this is the partial of effort respect to
Y compute from here I know by hypothesis
that the function I'm looking for must
have its partial respect to Y equal to
this consequently these two expressions
must be equal and equating these two
expressions says that G prime of Y C X
plus D prime of y must equal minus X
transposing says that G prime of Y is
minus 2x and this is a contradiction
because look at G prime of Y is a
function of Y alone and here we have
it's equal to some function of X or
another way of looking at it this says
that X depends on Y X is some function
of Y which is a contradiction since we
assume that x and y are independent
variables by the way just as a quick
aside notice that in the case where we
were able to succeed at this namely the
the previous example x squared + y DX
plus 2xy dy M was x squared plus y
squared n was 2xy notice that the
partial of M with respect to Y is 2y and
the partial of n with respect to X is
also 2y so it seems that the deciding
factor really seems to be that the
partial of M with respect to Y has to
equal the partial of n with respect to X
and the major result is and I didn't
write this in quezon one use up too much
space but this is emphasized in the text
and in the exercises if M and M sub y
and n sub X all exist in are continuous
then not only can we say that M DX plus
n dy is exact implies this part but we
can do the converse to that in
particular if M sub y equals n sub X we
can conclude that this is exact and the
reason for this now go through this very
quickly because the proof is given in
the text I just want to show you the
highlights of what happens is what
really happened when we try to construct
F that made things
work in one case but not in the other I
think the best way to do this is to work
abstractly here without specifying what
m and n are and see what happens what we
were trying to solve was a pair of
equations who was trying to find F such
as the partial of F with respect to X is
M partial of F with respect to Y is n
the first thing that we did was we
treated Y as a constant
and integrated this with respect to X
well I can't do this specifically
because I don't know when M is so let me
just put the integral sign in here to
say what I'm integrating this with
respect to X treating Y as a constant
that's some function of x and y you see
over here see M is a function of x and y
I'm holding Y constant I'm integrating
this plus a constant of integration
which depends only on Y all right
same as before what was my next step I
took the partial of this with respect to
F with respect to Y and I was going to
compare that with what I knew the
partial of F with respect to Y had to be
namely n so I then took what the partial
of this with respect to Y that gave me
the partial of this integral respect to
Y plus G prime of Y and equating that to
n I get the G prime of Y was n minus the
partial respect to Y integral M DX and
again don't be alarmed by this
expression if M had been given
explicitly I would have solved
explicitly for what this function was
the key point is to notice that this
side here is independent of X
consequently this equation will be a
contradiction unless the right-hand side
is a function of X in other words M is
independent of X in other words we have
determined F up to this function G of Y
and what's going to happen is we are
going to be able to compute G of Y if
this expression is independent of X
namely just by integrating this but if
if G of Y is not independent of X we are
in trouble it means that it's not going
to exist the key step is is this
independent of X and the answer is the
best way to find out in terms of
calculus is to take its derivative with
respect to X if this depends on Y alone
it's partial with respect to X must be 0
in other words if this passed
with respect to X is not zero it means
that this expression varies with X at
any rate to see what this derivative is
we just differentiate term by term and
then we say you know it's rather
interesting if this thing had been first
notice that if you integrate with
respect to X and then differentiate with
respect to X you wind up with just the
integrand well again if we have enough
continuity the order of differentiation
is irrelevant we can reverse the order
without changing anything
if we now interchange this order take
the partial first with respect to X that
will give us just M and the partial of M
with respect to Y is just the partial of
M with respect to Y of course what we're
saying is that from this step we get to
this step and this in turn implies this
notice that the only way that this can
be 0 is if the partial of n with respect
to X equals the partial of M with
respect to Y so in summary then this is
a very interesting device it tells us
how to tell whether a differential is
exact and the proof is very nice in this
case because the proof exactly imitates
how we construct the function f if it
turns out to be exact but the point is
if given MDX plus NDY if the partial of
M with respect to Y is not equal to the
partial of n with respect to X there's
no hope that the function will be exact
the differential will be exact
any rate we will have sufficient
exercises for drill and how one uses
exact differentials this concludes block
3 of our material our next block of
material which will conceal concern
linear systems of equations we'll begin
with our next lecture and until next
time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate